what has to happen before americans
get more freedoms i look at it as a
public health measure to prevent people
from dying and going to the hospital you
don't think americans liberties have
been threatened last year dr fauci
they've been assaulted
their liberties have i don't look at
this as a liberty thing
what number do we get our liberties back
tell me the number
give me the number
the mainstream media is going after ohio
congressman jim jordan over that he
did exchange between him and dr anthony
fauci reporters lashing out at the
congressman
and republicans generally for
challenging experts over restrictions
you have to be a [ __ ] to believe it but
there are i guess a lot of morons
out there jim jordan peddles those lies
this is fundamentally about the attack
on science
and data having to deal with
that misinformation disinformation
anti-vaxxers conspiracy theories
all of it you know i usually favor
jim jordan over those fellows that we
just played however
i have to say martha that i i thought
jim jordan was kind of nutty
attacking anthony fauci and saying that
it's an issue
of liberty when you have 550 000 dead
yeah well you know what we have an
enormous
amount of loss in this country i think
everybody knows somebody who has been
impacted by this on the other hand this
to say that that this is negating
science and data
well i don't understand why all of these
people can't see the huge
the larger picture of what's happened in
this country the
impact on people's lives outside of
covet
is so devastating and i think it's going
to take us years to recover from
you have people who are not working you
have companies who are
begging for people to come back to work
and to come back to their jobs but you
have you know these coveted relief bills
that are keeping people
from doing that in some cases that's a
fact of the matter just talk to any
company across the country
who's trying to find workers you have
the devastation of our cities
you have buildings that are boarded up
you have people who have nowhere to go
you have increase in homicides all
across the country
you have strife the likes of which we
haven't seen
in decades in this country and if you
don't think those things are
all related in some way i have
another story to tell you and and i
think that dr fauci you know knows what
he knows
but what what jim jordan was getting at
was the devastation that's happened to
this country i don't even i think
there's still so much shock i don't
think people even realize
how extensive the damage to the country
is by some of these decisions that were
made in terms of
the lockdowns and the response to covid
and yet uh jesse how do you feel about
wearing masks for example washing your
hands for example
uh you know social distancing aren't
those all things that
anthony tauchi has been preaching and
aren't they good advice
jess they are good advice but
he was asked a scientific question and
the scientist
sounded like a politician he dodged he
wouldn't answer the question
all he said was when as a scientist can
we go back to normal
i'll answer it for him because he
couldn't you can go back to normal
when you've been vaccinated because
according to all the studies if you've
been vaccinated
you have a .01 percent chance of
catching covet
i don't understand these liberals
seraldo they've been fully vaccinated
they're 35 years old
i see them walking around in central
park 40 feet away from people they're
double masking
and they won't even do inside dining
it's like they want to be shut down
and there's another study you can't you
can't catch covet on these packed
beaches
another study you can't catch covet on
surfaces we lysol the whole country
that's good i guess but you can't catch
it there there's no transmissions taking
place inside restaurants
less than one percent so that montage
you played of all those msnbc people
that's the science and i'm following it
jesse waters the science guy
okay jesse we got you judge jeanine
do you wear a mask and do you think that
uh
fauci's advice is is uh
significant than jim jordan's uh
political
feelings on this well well look fouchy
didn't really give us any advice the
last thing i heard was 15 days and then
it was no mask and then it was a mask
and now double mask
after you after you have a vaccine and
then cliver
jumps in he says things will be normal
after 90 percent of congress gets
vaccinated look
here's the bottom line the states that
were shut down the most
have the highest covert rates like new
york new jersey california
if you try to make this thing anything
other than what it is
then what we've got is a recognition
that the democrats
have decided that this is what we're
going to do i wear a mask when i'm with
people
i don't want them outside when i'm in my
car or when i'm with my family
but at the end of the day there's so
much devastation and i don't know
uh martha you did a tremendous list did
you include schools in there too
i mean you're not going to get uh covet
from school so
it's time for everybody to loosen up
lighten up and start living again
sean duffy you're a you know a guy that
knows his way around
you know sean one question going back to
the biden press conference we we saw
with the japanese prime minister
i didn't hear president biden say for
sure
that american athletes are actually
going to the tokyo games did you
hear that assurance i heard him say the
president supports
uh you know tokyo and the olympics but i
didn't hear him say
that america's athletes are definitely
going
what are you are they so what would you
do i think that's a good question harold
i don't know but i think if uh joe biden
was thinking about sending it not
sending our athletes he would
you know show us some skirt on that he
hasn't done that so i don't read much
into it let me just make a quick point
on faucet this was really easy
jim jordan asked about you a question
when do we get back to normal and
thought you said well we have 60 000
infections a day
so jordan said well what does it have to
get down to before we go back to normal
and fauci couldn't answer it listen this
is simple data this is simple science
you should be able to answer the
question fauci on when we go back to
normal
and he just he i mean he just danced as
jesse said he was playing mr politician
ridiculous and then maxine waters he
didn't show the clip of maxine waters
tells
uh uh jim jordan to shut his mouth this
was
insane sometimes it happens to me jim
jordan's head looked like it was going
to blow up and i think he's got to cool
down
up